you can sense that I mean I I remember
the first time I met I'm Meryl Streep
was at this theater that I told you
about the Phoenix Theater and she walked
in and she had her pants old tied up
because she was riding a bike to the
audition and she had a wheel her we love
her back in her hands and her hair was
all messy and I thought oh my god she's
glorious she is she's just beautiful and
so you do get those feelings you do you
are drawn to people that you know come
in come sit down next to you and talk to
you and you see something maybe they're
not necessarily right for the part but
there's something about their
personalities maybe you want to put them
in another role but yes the room changes
the color change is usually gold and
golden golden yellow i think is for me I
get a very excited and you know and try
to place these performers in in in
either the role that they've come in for
or in another part I like to think that
when I cast a movie or even work on a
movie that it would be a movie that
people will see a hundred years from now
I think that's why I always look at
things like will people look at this
project is moving this actor in hundred
years in the same way we look at Betty
Davis and in cary grant and humphrey
bogart and and i think we're looking at
them for a very long time I think that's
the the goal to see that talent that you
say
will last forever and ever and ever